well in one of the ways we can get them
more comfortable is because it's a
simulation and the patient is either a
mannequin patient or an actor patient
who's not going to be harmed or hurt by
what's done or not done is we could
literally and we do come in in the
middle of that situation we literally
press pause we're like pause patients
not going to get any better not gonna
get any worse let's just think this
through what are the signs and symptoms
you're concerned about what are the
signs and symptoms you're concerned
about yes how are you thinking about
moving forward how are you thinking
about moving forward so they can hear
each other's plans they can calm down a
little bit talk it out and then we
literally rewind a minute or two start
it back up so it's sort of like a live
video game yes and they can reorganize
themselves boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host on
shotgun very excited we are in Boston
Massachusetts we are going to be talking
about healthcare simulation we are at
the Center for medical simulation we are
sitting down with dr. Jenny Rudolph
hello good to meet you Alan thank you so
much for coming on the show and it's
great that Matthew your brother ended up
introducing us and I'm very excited to
talk to you I just had an incredible
experience here at your Center for
medical simulation where I experienced
one myself and it was very inspiring for
me and we'll have some videos embedded
that will show people what this is like
we're gonna be breaking this down for
those that don't know Jenny's background
she's the executive director at the
Center for medical simulation where she
creates learning oriented cultures in
healthcare she's also on the faculty at
Massachusetts General Hospital in the
department of anesthesia critical care
and pain medicine as well as in the
department of anesthesia at Harvard
Medical School and you can find the link
in the bio to Harvard medicine org as
well as Jenny's LinkedIn her Twitter and
the medical simulation Twitter account
as well all right so let's start things
off with our one of our favorite ways to
start things off which is we love asking
our guests we find ourselves as stewards
of Earth what is your current take on
the state of you
manatee I'd say my biggest concern for
us right now is certainty too many of us
are certain we're right and are not
curious enough about other people's
perspectives and I think that gets us in
a hole where it's really hard for us to
understand what other people care about
and therefore much harder for us to
bridge from our point of view to
somebody else's and so I think as my mom
Suzanne Hobart Rudolph wrote about that
can cause people in different countries
to get very solid views of each other
that are very hard to move they can
cause people within our own country to
get very rigid ways of viewing each
other it makes it very hard for us to
come to compromise invent new policies
that might help with global warming or
with income inequality etc and I think
if we can learn to be curious about each
other's point of view hold each other in
high regard those kinds of things could
be bridged better and jenny has this
really cool acronym WTF which instead of
what the she has is what the frame
what's the frame and that's great
because then it gets people to think
behind the other person's perspective
what is their frame what is their
perspective why do they potentially
think the way they do and I like how you
said certainty when we see things as a
probability curve we see a lot of people
saying I'm a hundred percent certain
that this is the right way and then they
can't have discourse about about things
and so if you think that hey maybe I can
be humble I can be curious I could say I
don't know everything and that we can
maybe tackle some of these challenging
issues of wealth and khloé climate
change global cohesion on these complex
exponential technologies that are
occurring that was a wonderful answer
Jenny let's jump into your journey so
you're born here in the Boston area and
then you find yourself getting into
excited about medicine at University of
Chicago then at Harvard and then now
here as the executive director doing
some professorship along the way teach
us about this journey
and how you picked up your interests
sure so it really came from being I
think a lifelong athlete I played
basketball in college I played
basketball in high school and I rode
crew on the US team one day when I was
watching the thirty-fourth video of
myself
rowing down the Charles River something
occurred to me I was like wow only we
could practice and watch videos and
rehearse on things that really matter
like health care or any complex
technology or or industry and so at not
long after that I was doing a PhD in
organizational behavior and I thought
wow is there anywhere any places where
people are practicing and of course
there are a lot in maritime shipping in
aviation and nuclear power and in
healthcare so I thought how can I get to
play basically for a living and I think
simulating practicing trying doing it
over video is a form of play which I
also think is very generative for us
adults who tend to take ourselves too
seriously so that was kind of how I got
into it yeah this is a cool story
because you you know you're we when
you're in Boston you see this Charles
River and you see these the teams of
rowing that they're you know in their
long what do you call the bowels they're
in their long shells in this way 7/8 of
yeah so they very there's eight spores
twos 814 those and you see like eight of
them really like you know rowing and
they're moving quite fast yeah and
they're you were on the US team which of
the u.s. crew furrowing which is really
interesting and then when you're doing
that you like you said this thirty
fourth replay of watching yourself and
you're like let's apply this to two
real-world ways of becoming better in
the you know healthcare simulation in
aviation simulation is already happening
and so we're now seeing this an
engineering software we're seeing this
in manufacturing simulation of designing
certain parts of aviation all these all
these different fields of aerospace
engineering it's in biotechnology it's
now getting more and more popular you
know the show is called simulation
and it's becoming more and more popular
for us to figure out what is the highest
greatest fit for in a case and in your
case it was how do we how do we maximize
the the experience of the patient and
the practitioners the physicians the
nurses that are working on the patient
and there's so much nuance and
complexity that we'll get into I'm
really happy that that the story makes
so much cool sense on you getting
involved in this and then so now tell us
about this this trajectory for you once
you saw how did you envision
implementing it so in my ph.d program I
got really interested in Industrial
Safety and particularly perhaps because
of my athletics background I was really
interested in what we call high hazard
industries sometimes called high
reliability industry depending on your
point of view so high hazard industries
are generally ones where things are
tightly coupled and somewhat complex so
you've got processes that have to go
just perfectly for everything to line up
and everybody to stay safe for example
in nuclear power or chemical processing
and I realized that without mindfulness
and awareness it was really easy to make
mistakes because vigilance is almost
impossible to maintain so I was
interested in the systems part of that
you can't maintain vigilance it's
basically impossible there's research on
quote unquote normal accidents that they
will happen sometimes regardless of all
of our best planning because things line
up in unexpected ways but I was really
interested in the human performance part
of it and so I started looking around
for where could I study that what could
I do with that and I started by learning
about how do we prevent and learn from
accident and error in these high hazard
industries during that period My partner
was pregnant with our first baby and I
thought I need something to study that's
nearby and close here in Boston and so
that got me interested in
simulation healthcare simulation world
and I stumbled upon the Center for
medical simulation here and thought this
would be a great place to do my doctoral
dissertation because medical error
healthcare error is actually quite rare
and I'd have to watch a lot of
healthcare provision to find a few small
mistakes but here at the Center for
medical simulation and a lot of other
simulation centers we push people to
work at the edge of their expertise so
it's common that they Zig when they wish
they had zagged almost every single day
and so I could study what was happening
in that context yeah the love you know
you're using this like at the edge cases
or or in the these error cases the we
follow a procedure a lot we follow like
an algorithm for a certain procedure in
nuclear or in or in manufacturing or and
even when we're doing a sport we're
following certain algorithms and
especially when you're a physician
you're you know you're following
algorithms and and so what happens when
you get a curve ball that's thrown at
you when you have an edge case an error
how can we know how to which which line
of of trajectory do we transition to
that has the highest rate of efficacy of
you know making sure that the patient is
safe and healthy and and the procedure
goes as as as well as possible and and I
really like envisioning it as as a sport
because of the you know that totally
makes sense the connection between your
sport profession as well as your medical
simulation and then okay so then the
implementation of it so then you like
using you told me as this like this goal
better outcomes for our patients and
helping clinicians field mastery and
there's an there's a massive exponential
growth of this that's happening you said
over the last 15 years it's just been
hockey sticking up you have people from
around the world even today yeah you
know visiting yeah so tell us about this
goal and and how its
happening here so I think I'll talk
about this Allen in terms of how do you
create simulations and how do you
educate people to be really good
simulation educators so let's imagine
that I've got a resident who's in
emergency medicine and he or she has a
young kid who's come to the emergency
department and they've been in an
accident and they're in shock and they
need more volume whether it's blood
volume or more just more fluid in their
body to maintain their their blood
pressure one of the ways that that can
get done when you need to get a lot of
fluid in all at once or if there's if
you're having difficulty getting it in
via normal IVs as you put in something
called an intraosseous line and that is
something that you basically put in
through the skin into the bone itself
mmm so it's a little bit of a scary
procedure for people to learn for the
first time and so what we think about is
what are the different things you would
have to be able to master to put in an
IO line and one is actually putting in
the line itself at the procedure but the
second is imagine an anxious mom or dad
standing there seeing you with this
giant thing that you're about to put
into their kids leg and they start
freaking out
so there's several things that you have
to master as that resident one is the
procedure one is managing the anxious
parent one may be managing your internal
self so when you made the analogy to
sports one of the connections is this
process of mastery learning or
deliberate practice where you practice
get feedback try it again try it again
so we break that process up into
different pieces for people so one might
be practicing the procedure just getting
your hands and feet in the right place
and putting it in the right place in the
patient the other might be the difficult
conversation with the parent so mom you
know bear with me here and how you would
talk with the parent or you would assign
someone to talk with the parents yeah
yeah this is this is you're really
hitting
from a way and we try our best to help
on the show make it clear about the
nuance and the complexity of our of our
world and when you take a procedure and
you start explaining that hey it's not
just you know it's not just roses it's a
hook and edges be completely smooth with
every single time there's so many
variables at play so so not only do we
have to get good at building the mastery
at the actual procedure itself the
physical eradication of an issue or the
amelioration of the health of
augmentation of the health and in any
way but also we have to deal with a
potentially a parent that is concerned
we also have to deal with something
another variable that's happening in the
procedure that like we had a hypotension
issue earlier that will yeah we'll get
to so if something like that happens how
does the team react to that so there's
all these cool ways that you're there
you're running simulations and just for
for everyone to get an idea of you know
what this actually looks like you can
see this video that were you know
embedding right now that you know
they're these you have these you have
the actual simulation rooms where
there's an actual patient and a
practicing table with all the
instruments you know you see the heart
rate and you see the blood pressure
levels and then you also there's a
there's a room outside of that which is
kind of like the control center where
your viewing what's happening you can
hear the physicians and nurses
describing what's a current and their
procedures you're videotaping that so
they can then debrief on what happened
in so yeah so teach us about this cuz
that was so fascinating for us sure so
one way to think about this is practice
if any buddy who's watching this
practice learned an instrument or worked
on their free throw shots in basketball
or hit tennis shots as we know you have
to hit thousands of tennis balls to be
able to hit a good topspin in a game
the clinicians who come to our center
practice hundreds of hours every year
thousands of hours every year in their
discipline but they rarely have the
opportunity to practice step back
observe and think about their thinking
so we really break this down into three
parts we think about what are the
clinical results or psychosocial results
so think about that example did the kid
get the volume did the kid get the blood
into them they needed did the mom get
talked to in a compassionate way so the
result would be the mom would be calm
the kid would be stabilized I
hemodynamically the actions that the
clinicians take that's the second thing
we think about what are they doing or
not doing saying or not saying so we can
help them learn different steps of
conversations or different clinical
procedures or whatever the third piece
though is what we really focus on so
there's clinical results
there's actions taken or not taken but
then there's the thinking or the frames
of the clinicians when they're doing
things so most of us humans to do an
expert procedure or whether it's play a
musical instrument
or take care of a patient we have a
whole complex routine of thoughts and
feelings and expertise that we're
blending all together to produce those
actions so what we do in simulation is
you can practice the actions but then
you get to press pause and either go
into a debriefing and take some time and
reflect on your thinking by talking
about it with other colleagues or you
can literally press pause in the middle
of the simulation and sort of like a
video game live die repeat you're just
going to that it's not actually a real
patient it's a mannequin patient or an
actor patient who's not going to be
harmed or hurt by anything we're doing
so you can pause think about what you're
doing
whine the situation back a few minutes
and try it again so it's all about the
deliberate practice of getting better at
whatever you're doing yes yes yeah as as
you're explaining that to I was I was
thinking about as these
simulations become so indistinguishable
from reality that it will also be
powerful because then people could
really not have that going on in their
head that all this is just a simulation
so I may not have to treat this
seriously as I should be so there's
almost a very strange dynamic that will
occur when it becomes so you know
indistinguishable but I mean I build on
yeah so that will be wonderful and that
may happen but part of the art of good
healthcare simulation or any simulation
is we try to create something called a
fiction contract which is this idea that
I've made it real enough physiologically
emotionally and experientially and
conceptually such that like if the blood
pressure drops and you give a medication
that should raise the blood pressure the
blood pressure will come back up so the
world is functioning the way you expect
even if the manikin is a plastic
mannequin that looks sort of real not
that real what we find is people are
very able to buy in and participate with
their heart and mind if we make it real
enough and importantly we make it
psychologically safe enough so your
professional skills are on display like
let's say we were doing a simulation of
an interview and then we paused it we
debriefed to do that you'd want to feel
like hey you know people care about me
here they're here to help me become a
better interviewer or maybe I'm doing
media training they're here to help me
be a better interviewee it can't be a
kind of gotcha environment so we can get
people to be act as if it's real with a
surprisingly low level of fidelity or
realism yeah yet the the trust that
there has to be built in see of
environment that people can feel like
you were like you you describe that it's
so crucial for them to feel like they
can
voice how they feel because it's almost
as though we have to become more and
more comfortable with the dynamically
shifting patient care environment to say
how we think the next part of the
procedure should go and if we feel
comfortable voicing it then in practice
then we will in the in actual
environment and so building that sort of
a culture between physicians and nurses
when all these different things are
shifting with with parents or family as
well as the actual physical procedure
and all the variables that are being
tweaked along the way let's let's give
let's give the actual example that that
that we had okay we were watching an
appendectomy so there was just about a
little over an hour ago there was a
simulation occurring where the
physicians and nurses on the operating
table who were working on a patient the
simulated patient with with with the the
process was to remove the appendix and
there was oh this is very interesting we
you know I called it a curveball and I
will let you explain but the general
idea is that you through anaphylaxis at
the team and the the anaphylaxis caused
it caused a hypotension
it caused a rash it caused a bunch of
things that then they had to dynamically
adjust you so this was very fascinating
for me watching it and seeing a a
simulated environment of it because now
they know what to do when this edge case
happens in the real world and they can
be prepared to to to save the patient
and there was even the epinephrine drip
that was occurring and how much of it
you needed to give in order to kick the
you know the body into action to fight
and athil axis so yes please explain
this it was so cool watching it him then
in the control room those
you know there were people we were
listening to them watching them and yeah
well let me I'll do my best to explain
it with the caveat that I'm an
organizational behavior scholar and not
a clinician so I'm gonna explain it
somewhat conceptually but with a few
clinical examples so what we would like
to do in healthcare simulation is
prepare people for things that they are
going to face so if they if that was
your mom on the table or your dad on the
table you would like them to be very
comfortable with anaphylaxis happening
in the middle of an operation that one
of your loved ones was having and be
able to quickly know what were the
medications they need to give and so on
we try to help people in our simulation
center there's lots of different kinds
of simulations but here we tend to help
people work at the edge of their
expertise we have advanced practitioners
who are already capable of managing
fairly complex challenges so in this
case an appendectomy is a pretty
bread-and-butter surgery surgery even a
minimally invasive one which was what
was what's happening in anaphylaxis is
pretty bread-and-butter problem for many
people in the textbook mm-hmm so it's
possible for you to go through ten years
of practice and you know all about the
signs and symptoms of anaphylaxis but
you have never actually treated it
yourself you and the other thing is the
textbook presentation of anaphylaxis
which is an allergic reaction could be
hypotension which is a drop in blood
pressure a rash wheezing a variety of
other things but what my clinical
colleagues in this course and others
have told me is anaphylaxis doesn't
always present in the textbook manner
and so what we're trying to prepare
people for is their own autonomic
nervous system reaction their own stress
which can kind of shut down how their
brain actually thinks just like any
other person so you've got to calm
yourself down rethink what's going on
assess the signs and symptoms and figure
out how to manage the patient sometimes
with additional
complexities in the presentation of the
patient themselves so it might be a
bread and butter and a flexus it might
be a bread and butter appendectomy but
maybe there's something complex about
the patient that makes it extra
difficult and so we're looking for
people to be able to apply the knowledge
they have in a situation that's new for
them yeah yeah there's a couple things
there one of the things was the
physicians and nurses we typically don't
think need to be good practitioners of
meditation or mindfulness but ones
ability to to see a you know a stressful
situation and not you know necessarily
panic but maybe you know take a deep
breath realize okay what do we need to
do to best handle this right now and
then take it from a very you know
logical procedural perspective and then
also the I love how you keep describing
this state of of flow it's it's almost
as though yet you're challenging people
right at their expertise of level I'm
not too easy but it's not yeah too hard
and then they're there right in that
state of their optimal cognitive
challenge and then by doing that that's
how they keep becoming a master in what
they're what they're working on
may I build a second yes so one of the
things that's important is simulation is
expensive it's expensive in time it's
expensive in space it's expensive and
equipment so anybody can study what are
the signs and symptoms of anaphylaxis
what are the first-line treatments I
could you could study that and I could
give you a test of that tomorrow and you
could probably answer a lot of questions
correctly what we're trying to do is
create this context where people where
it's valuable to work at the edge of
your expertise are sorry to take the
value of all this expensive input and
help people at the edge of their
expertise for just about the knowledge
they don't need simulation if we're just
about the experience which they get
every single day they don't need
simulation it's the unique combination
of practice plus debriefing plus
reflection that helps you get in that
deliberate practice improvement but yeah
that's very very well put and there's
actually you know like Achille
interactive one of the really great
progress is that we've made in digital
medicine kind of takes people to their
optimal level of cognitive challenge
with with increasing certain areas of
their of their cognitive processing
maybe a working memory or they're just
attention all these focus right so so
it's it's as though you've created a
similar you know closed-loop feedback
system with people being at their
optimal level of cognitive challenge in
an experiential environment versus a
textbook environment like you're
indicating earlier which just has you
know we're seeing today with the advent
of like spatial computing in the 3d
virtual reality augmented reality spaces
is just when you envision an actual
biological system in the 3d space you
can tweak it it's much greater level of
of remembering and and under learning
than it is on a 2d page so you'd have
experience illan vironment then you go
and do the debriefing side of things
which then you're having discourse
amongst your peers about what was what
you could what you learned what you
could do better and then you go into
another one it's just this is a very
very beautiful process that you've that
you built here and okay so then it it's
also interesting that you have this
process I want to talk about the the
actual debriefing and - the assessment
please teach us about that sure
so we were approached a number of years
ago by a colleague who was involved with
the American Heart Association adam
chang who was really interested in how
do we get novice educators to be better
at the very very important task of
helping people be better in managing
cardiac arrest and he had some different
ideas about how to do that and he came
to me and my colleague robert simon and
he said i'd like to be able to assess
the quality of the debrief
after they practice doing a code
resuscitation what is the impact of the
debriefing on the learning can you give
me can what's your assessment tool and
we said um we don't have one but we
thought hmm challenge so Robert Simon is
a psychometrician I'm a organizational
behavior psychologist with an interest
in conversation and cognition and we got
busy with our simulation colleague Dan
Raymer and working with a variety of
colleagues all over the world we created
an instrument to assess the quality of
debriefing so that doesn't sound all
that interesting but what's really cool
about it is it gives a common language a
common set of standards a common
parlance that we can all use then to
create a community of people who knows
how to have this technical conversation
better better better
so the dash has been translated into
about six different languages it's about
to come out in Mandarin it's a Arabic
translation is underway and what's neat
about that is simulation programs in
Riyadh or in Beijing or in Santander
Spain get together work on giving each
other feedback on their debriefing again
who cares the reason I care and the
reason I think it's really important is
debriefing is a stylized way to practice
having difficult conversations all of us
humans hate the awkwardness of
critiquing another person we would just
rather do you know have a root canal
practically instead of that but what the
- or debriefing getting better
debriefing helps you do is learn how you
can be curious and assume the best of
the other person which solves this
horrible dilemma of having to basically
cover over my feelings and lie to you
about the critique and just hope that
you're gonna guess why you did it wrong
so what we focus on is I can be straight
with you about the critique because
you're intelligent capable trying to do
your best and want to improve I'm
thinking that about you which reduces
my anxiety and social awkwardness and
lets me tell you the truth in a kindly
way yes and so the - helps build
communities that can do that better you
you know this this behavior science side
of things the perspective that you take
there about building out the
environments that make it people
comfortable with having a growth mindset
and comfortable with critique feedback
integration and then further practice is
being translated into Mandarin and
Arabic that's huge it's billions of
people that's awesome and I love the you
know the debriefing side is such a
critical you know you guys will have a
video here embedded as well where you
can see the sitting around the table
having discussion watching the video
replay of what happened in the medical
simulation with the patient and with
everyone moving in you know being able
to pause it being able to rewind it
fast-forward it jump to the different
highlighted annotation points was really
cool yeah yeah that part was very
interesting as well like when the actual
allergic reaction happened you can kind
of like find that area and go to it
exactly right yeah that's that's very
cool and then you can rewatch how people
yeah behaved at that moment so what
we've been talking about this individual
skill development and and cognition
improvement and self-management
improvement you could think about that
as the core of an onion of performance
improvement but I'd like to just mention
a couple other ways that that's
spreading out in the simulation world
especially related to some of the other
technological developments you mentioned
so for example with 3d printing our
colleagues at the Boston Children's
Hospital Peter Weinstock and others have
worked with their surgical colleagues to
create a process whereby if there's a
child coming in for neurosurgery they
use the CT scan of that child's brain
produce a 3d model of that child's brain
and then the neurosurgeons can practice
what's the route to get into for example
a tumor before
the child is even on the operating table
greatly reducing the amount of time that
the kid needs to be under anesthesia and
in reducing some of the uncertainty of a
very complex procedure so that is
happening around the world we need to do
that yes let's make that one happened -
that would be fast and loose we can
actually yeah we can model the actual
patient's biological systems and then go
and practice on their exact biological
systems like tumor or whatever the
ailment is and then practice on on
removing that and and get mastery on it
and then actually do it on the patient
holy cow that's great yeah yeah so and
then another application that's
happening again using kind of
stimulation to look at the systems of
care is a colleague in Australia named
Victoria Brazel and team at the Gold
Coast University Hospital have been
using simulation to map out the patient
journey but also build interprofessional
knowledge and trust so let me tell you
what all those terms mean so imagine
that you want to get the patient from
who's having a some kind of a heart
attack a STEMI from the door of the
emergency department to the cath lab for
definitive treatment they have to come
from the ambulance and the pre-hospital
providers through the emergency
department transported through the
hospital up to the cath lab nobody
really understands what each other's
roles are there they're sometimes
misunderstandings even conflict between
this and we can set up a situation where
people can wear GoPros and see each
other's part of the process and Victoria
and team debrief 4050 people all
together who can see that entire process
and so they learn about each other's
roles and build trust among each other
so it's very easy to focus on the
technology but what simulation really is
an excuse to do is understand each
other's thinking better so going back to
the very
the interview what I'm passionate about
is how do we build how do we come to
each other from sort of a stance of
curiosity and respect when we do these
interprofessional simulations people get
more curiosity and more respect about
each other's roles yeah yeah
similarly please it was so cool all the
way to the actual EMTs that are sitting
in that ambulance yeah and having that
GoPro so that you know the physicians
and nurses and staff at hospital can see
what they're experiencing with the
patient while they're being transported
all the way to like you said just all of
the complexity that actually occurs at
the hospital being able to get behind
with the curious curiosity behind the
eyes of every single one of those people
along the way you're building that trust
it's it is such an interdisciplinary
field and to be able to take care of the
patient oh yeah give us more of these
examples okay well there's a another one
that I think is really interesting and
important which is testing out whether
architectural designs actually work for
patient safety and patient care so
colleagues at the Mater health services
in Brisbane Australia that team at
Boston Children's that I mentioned
earlier the team at Texas Children's
Team all Johns Hopkins all Children's in
Florida all of them have different ways
of bringing simulation to a building
basically bring a patient bring the
people so for imagine that you're
building a pediatric intensive care
units or let's say regular intensive
care unit you build a room that was it
has a bed and a sink and all these
different things it looks great but what
you hadn't thought about is if that kid
all of a sudden crashes and needs to be
on something called ECMO or you need to
bring a defibrillator in there or you
need to bring ECMO in there and the
defibrillator was already in there and
the ten people that go with all that
equipment and all the plugs and all the
cords and all the noise and all of a
sudden all those things don't actually
even fit in that room yeah and you can't
take
care of the child so simulation is being
used to help plan to do mid-course
testing on architectural designs and
then to test after the design is done so
huge cost savings but also important
safety advances yeah so architectural
speaking can the room where the
patient's being operated on fit the
anomaly case equipment that needs to be
brought into the room how noisy will it
be can it be plugged in all this yeah
all these how many more staff members
are gonna be in the room to do that part
of it do they how will they know the
patient's data you had this you know
love that love this an image embedded
here where you actually have a
whiteboard in the in the operating room
with the the the data on the patient
their you know their date of birth their
their right like their if they have any
allergies if they have the actual health
record number yeah itself but Alan let
me just I hasten to say I think a lot of
my colleagues would really love it if we
could go back to having whiteboards
everywhere many of my colleagues are now
working with an electronic medical
record or an integrated electronic
medical record which is supposed to make
life easier but if you imagine that now
you have all these doctors nurses
respiratory therapists other allied
health who are supposed to be looking at
patient and each other are now also on
top of that basically having to do data
entry the data entry on top and so the
into the electronic medical record it
adds a level of complexity that we're
also trying to understand using
simulation because it completely changes
the relationships in the room not only
with notation that's right with each
other yeah when we had dr. Robert Lustig
on the show he made it very clear that
he and a lot of the other physicians
around the world have found it to be
quite difficult to you know you're the
doctor and I'm the patient and you're
spending you know a part of the time
looking at me and empathizing with me
and then part of the
looking at a device and entering data
into a device and then that whole
processes it takes you longer it's a and
it's also very important that that
electronic medical or health record can
then also be read by the other that the
data can very easily move around that I
can retain some ownership of the data
there's all these can that data then be
used for metal further medical research
do I have control that there's so many
of these questions and it makes a lot of
sense to define the most frictionless
process of being able to potentially
capture what the physicians and nurses
are saying by voice and then find the
key phrases parse for the key phrases
enter that in great electronic medical
record that'd be fantastic hopefully the
algorithms that we're working on will be
able to get us to that point there's I
mean there's so many so much else that
that we can talk about with the examples
I think this is an interesting one since
this was this was just happening we had
we had one of the midwifery nurses
visiting for physicians I'm visiting
from Belgium yep so we had and this was
just one just happening a little over an
hour ago
you know people from around the world
you usually have about four or so like
let's say anesthesiologists that come in
and that they're training they're from
mass gen massachusett 'el and they're in
their training on how to become a better
is easy ologist with these simulations
but then you can also have people from
around the world like from Belgium
coming to visit and so usually what the
midwife's doing is working with the
mother that's about to birth a child and
there can be complications that occur
like you were explaining the shoulder
could get you know stuck in the canal
and then there and then what so how do
you something like what these are the
things is how do you prepare the Midwife
to be able to handle a situation like
that through a simulation there can be
some nerve damage that occurs how do you
talk to the fam
after that so this is very beautiful you
were starting to teach me about this and
then so maybe walk us through some more
of these you know you have people
visiting from around the world and
they've they're in different fields and
you have different simulations for them
and then they take it back and teach
their part of the world about yeah so
just to set this context here and then
maybe pick an example that would
illustrate it so we have simulation
fellows that join us for three months to
12 months who come from whether it's
Germany or Spain or Saudi Arabia or
Belgium or wherever and they are working
on improving their simulation programs
whether they are skill based or system
based or these different kinds of
applications that we've discussed a lot
of what we specialize in is
interprofessional communication so how
do people from different professions
which often amounts to slightly
different cultures because how
professions are trained can be quite
different in what your expectations are
and your assumptions are work together
so let's take the labor and delivery
example that you gave so one of the
things that we sometimes practice here
is a mother who comes in let's say she's
had a motor vehicle accident or some
other kind of situation or condition
where she's deteriorating
maybe she's heading toward a heart
attack maybe she has some kind of a
cardiac arrhythmia at the same time the
baby maybe is having some fetal distress
so the problem is we've got to take care
of the mom and we've got to take care of
the baby and the people who are focused
on stabilizing the mom
often the anesthesiologist and the
people are focused on caring for the
baby
often the OBGYNs or the midwives or the
nurses have slightly competing
objectives there are certain things that
need to be done for the baby there are
certain things that need to be done for
the mom and they have to quickly
negotiate that in
maybe minutes or 90 seconds they have to
clarify what each other's goals are and
if they haven't been in that situation
quickly grasp that and find a way to
make a decision for example sometimes
it's going to be in the interest of both
mom and baby to do an emergency cesarean
section and get the baby out but to do
that requires certain preparations and
certain kinds of things for the mom
sometimes it might be better to do
something for the mom first and wait
before we deliver the baby imagine just
trying to figure that all out as the a
blood pressure is going down and the
heart rate is going up and fetal
monitors looking non reassuring these
are things that we try to help people
practice here and so returning to some
of the themes we've discussed that
involves self-management how do I calm
myself down so my colleague Rebecca
mynhardt who's an anesthesiologist and a
OB anesthesiologist has been doing a
study in one of our courses on how do
the clinicians perceive a crisis what is
a crisis to them what is it externally
what is it internally in terms of what
they feel and she's trying to understand
that so we can better build that into
our courses and prepare that help people
be prepared for self management then
there's organizing the team so for
example that anesthesiologist might need
to name the things that are happening
help people claim roles and then aim the
team with the intervention so we have a
algorithm as you've called it before
that's named claim aim that helps people
organize the team so those are some of
the different things that we might do in
that interprofessional way and Jennifer
Joris who's the Midwife visiting us from
Belgium and that you met is really
interested in that sort of
interprofessional coordination and
collaboration under stress and time
pressure Wow
that example in 90 seconds let's say to
have to logically talk about the
protocol the next step that's so crazy
yeah woman Wow the blood pressures
dropped
like what yeah and so these are you know
let's get behind the eyes of more people
you know everything from people that are
still using jerrican gallons to go and
get water from wells all the way to
people that are working in the
restaurants that were eating and
customers at all the way to the nurses
and physicians that are working on on
our loved ones and the more that we can
do that and and realize the complexity
of what their work is and and even
potentially you know do the simulations
that give people a more comfortable in
those environments with more mastery in
those environments well in one of the
ways we can get them more comfortable is
because it's a simulation and the
patient is either a mannequin patient or
an actor patient who's not going to be
harmed or hurt by what's done or not
done is we could literally and we do
come in in the middle of that situation
we've literally press pause we're like
pause patients not going to get any
better not gonna get any worse let's
just think this through what are the
signs and symptoms you're concerned
about what are the signs and symptoms
you're concerned about yes how are you
thinking about moving forward how are
you thinking about moving forward so
they can hear each other's plans they
can calm down a little bit
talk it out and then we literally rewind
a minute or two start it back up so it's
sort of like a live video game yes and
they can reorganize themselves it's so
cool yeah what do you you know when you
you know in many ways with this is this
is a game civilization that human
experiment earth is a game so you know
it would be fascinating to actually be
able to pause our game earth and go how
do we you know geopolitically handle
artificial intelligence let's take a
break yeah oh that would be so so
wonderful if you stop the world I want
to get off I need to think about how can
we slow down global warming here yeah
yeah because the fact that the economy
is just roaring at unprecedented speed
NEADS and causing us in many ways to not
be able to press the pause button there
just keeps us going every single day and
that's why we experience a lot of the
miscommunications and issues that we do
and we have no space for oops moments
yeah with the scale of errors that could
potentially be occurring yes okay this
has been this has been so fascinating
and I want to ask you about where you
see all of this going with the future of
healthcare the future of medical
simulations healthcare simulations where
do you see this moving to in the in the
future so I think there's kind of two or
three big trends that I think are
important and likely to get more
important so one is a our augmented
reality virtual reality and we're
working with a group called Erie al who
is synthesizing work from a bunch of
universities around Italy to bring AR
and VR to healthcare and I can talk more
about AR and VR one is integration of
simulation so we've learned into the
healthcare system and the third is using
it more for just-in-time type training
so we've already alluded to all three of
those so the AR VR is an area where
there's a number of companies that are
already trying to help us visualize for
example 3d models of things and be
actually in them and we know a lot about
the transfer from 3d to 2d that is
already showing for example in
mammography that we can have greater
accuracy and better prevention of
adverse outcomes with better
visualization this is not my area of
expertise but I believe it's something
that's going to be important the second
is this integration so I'm a simulation
East
they say but what I'm really keen to do
is how do we bring debriefing more and
more into just real clinical spaces we
don't need simulation we have hundreds
of cases every day thousands of cases
every day at Massachusetts General
Hospital or other could we have a mini
micro debrief of that are there ways
that we we're not going to practice on
our patients but there's a lot of what
we do that we could learn from if we
could have some little moments of
reflection but the other is to build it
into the context such that we are
testing our systems while building our
skills so we're actually in situ there's
a lot of Institute simulation happening
and I believe that's gonna expand in
some ways Institute in situ so right is
situation yep you miss it yeah so using
that what's a latin word yeah so in the
clinic in the home in the real clinic in
the real home in the in the in the
intensive care unit in the operating
room itself so people are using their
own equipment their own environment
their own electronic medical record and
those kinds of things allow us to learn
a lot more about the intersection of our
skills in our systems challenge there is
it's very expensive to be in any real
clinical space I can potentially take
the my own electronic health record and
and run like my own biometrics and
potentially run a simulation on what it
would be like if I if I took the
antibiotic that I needed to combat
something or that I need if I maybe
needed some sort of a desired a genetic
engineering procedure in order to see
what it would do to me potentially and
that that's interesting then of course
like taking and you leveraging the power
of computation and all the permutations
that really powerful computing can do in
the actual operating room and be able to
simulate out if we made this decision
and you know in just 90 seconds so here
are all the decisions the highest
efficacy is this one and you know to be
able to see which protocols best and
then of course like you said debriefings
or
the world if I was thinking about it'd
be great if there were you know two
teams tackling and that way the team
that tackles the surgery can then go
debrief for half an hour while the other
team goes and does the next one so that
it's not having to go from one to the
next to the next to the next there's no
debriefing time in between that was
interesting and then of course yeah we
have some great connections for you
we'll love to come connect you to
infinite retino we just had on the show
on spatial computing and augmented
reality and they already work with so
many healthcare organizations that are
using the technology to be able to have
that augmentation that three-dimensional
augmentation of the patient experience
to make sure it's of greater levels of
of efficacy awesome conversation in just
so mind-expanding I feel so much more
enlightened I want to ask you just two
questions that I would typically ask our
guests on the way out of the show first
questions of course funny and the car
given the context we're in are we in a
simulation well you and I did a little
bit of a pre briefing we thought a
little bit about what we would want to
do here and theoretically we could pause
at any time and rewind redo in fact we
should have done that that would have
been kind of fun I try to approach my
life as a little bit of a deliberately
developmental opportunity so or action
inquiry and I give myself as much slack
as I can to rewind and redo so even if
we're not going to immediately redo this
you know if this had been a real life
would we be doing this differently or is
life a simulation I like to think about
being able to practice and get better
though as you say it's a game with real
consequences yes so I will say parts of
life our simulation
yeah yeah how does a constant leveling
up and and knowing that it is building
our own our own skill sets and helping
contribute at the level of our family
community world is just so critical
brings us most meaning in life and and
that's what I think drives so much of
our existences so I'd like to just ask
you a question about simulation so I
noticed that the podcast is called
simulation and I was thinking wow Alan
must be into rehearsal practice
something why does he call it simulation
so why is your show culture
it's called simulation for so many
reasons you know it's so funny that you
know we are here Center for medical
simulation and I think that when you
take simulations and healthcare
simulations and engineering software to
find the right fit for aerospace or for
automotive or whatever industry on an
engineering software side of things or
there's there's simulations used for for
how to calculate the you know the
trajectory of the Rockets that need to
go to the International Space Station
you know there's the there's simulations
for for biology the central dogma of
biology and how that actually works when
you when you drop in you know the like
pharmaceuticals into the biological
system how that effects it I mean it's
endless where simulations are actually
applied already in an in real life and
so you know that's you know one of the
reasons of course another one of the
reasons is because this is the question
of if we are in a simulation is very
interesting and it also speaks greatly
to in the next couple of decades
hopefully within 50 years we'll be
running our own simulations and we'll be
able to do things like look back at at
how humans actually evolved from you
know from the Big Bang to the
development of the earth orbiting the
star to the development of
of life all the way up to civilization
flourishing and we can actually finally
look at all the artifacts the
archaeology of the Anthropology of the
evolution and we can not have to play
the guessing game we can actually watch
how language was invented how fire was
invented the wheel was invented and so
anyway that's these are the these are
the reasons why you are really attracted
to these abilities to kind of predict
and play out and that's why you named it
simulation or yeah yeah that and I would
also say that it's just a lot of the
shows about also asking really
thought-provoking questions to the
leaders at the edge of their fields and
inspiring and engaging other people to
get to the edge and work at the edge and
build the future and so you know the
thought-provoking question you know are
we in a simulation what is consciousness
are we alone in the cosmos the last
question we like to ask our guests is
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world
empathy compassion attunement being
together really was it was really raw
yeah yeah yeah and I hope that one of
the things for Millennials and for Gen Z
is really your what Jenny just said you
know really the empathy the attunement
the ability to get behind the others
eyes to be there with the presence with
the heart and the energy the spirit
right here you know is so so crucial so
to say that word you know with our
friends when we're time you're on the
devices is much much different so yeah
yeah thank you so much this is such a
great interview yes I love you and I
love your work so much thank you thank
you for all that you're doing for all
that the Center for medical simulation
is doing please check out the links
below all again the links are Harvard
med sim
org also Jenny's link to her LinkedIn
profile the med simulation on Twitter as
well as get curious now Jenny's Twitter
check out those links below everyone let
us know your thoughts about the episode
as well so share the thoughts around
medical simulation healthcare simulation
with your friends your family's online
with your coworkers
let's keep more talking about this let's
get behind eyes and physicians and the
caretakers the nurses that are helping
us live healthy lives and all the
complicated protocols that they go
through and also support the artists and
entrepreneurs and the organizations that
you believe in around the world
simulations links are below as well
support us help us scale help us grow
help us continue coming to cool places
like Boston to do interviews like this
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in